(audience cheering)
- This is kind of cool
because sometimes when you're in movies,
you don't know people,
but y'all have been
friends for a while, right?
- Yeah, long time.
- Yeah.
When did y'all meet?
- Well.
- (laughing) Well?
- [Kelly] Do you have different stories?
- Kathryn revealed to me only a month ago-
- Oh, that's right.
We met a long time ago.
- that she asked for a
photo of my twin and I
at Bob's Big Boy in Los Angeles.
- I was around seven years old.
Huge fan, obviously.
Who wasn't, right?
- Yeah.
- Everyone here is a fan?
(audience cheering)
And I'm lucky enough
to be one of the people
who got a picture with the Sprouse twins.
- I didn't remember the moment.
- No.
(audience laughing)
And I didn't tell him about
it until way, way into filming
because I wanted to
like be cool, you know?
I wanted be-
- Yeah.
- We're both actors.
Like, we're the same.
We're not the same.
(Kelly laughing)
- We are equals.
- We are not the same.
Not at all.
- Well, you did a photo shoot with,
'cause I mean, he's a photographer.
We talked about this last time.
But you did a photo shoot with him,
and it kind of was like
inspiring for this whole movie,
right?
- Yeah.
I, you know, I've seen Cole multiple times
throughout the years.
We met again when he was on "Riverdale"
and I was on "Supernatural."
and he kept talking about my poodles
'cause I have these crazy dogs.
And finally I asked you to just shoot
and he shot it in my
house with these wigs.
And it was like, you came
up with this narrative,
like a woman who killed all her husbands
and is just collecting dogs
and diamonds, you know?
And I feel like it was a
precursor to our film 'cause-
- Yeah, I gotta talk to my
therapist about that idea.
- [Kelly] Yeah, there's
a lot to dive in there.